my name is jack
and i'm a super dad
um i watch a lot of movies
um talk to my daughter a lot
um yeah i'm a i'm a john hughes fan
um breakfast club is on your fingers
what is that flubber
it's fire yeah you like plumber
i have i haven't even thought about
flubber until just this very instant i
don't know why would
life flubber over anything else i mean
blubber's just dope yeah he's like a
scientist
who made this uh this goo that like
bounces everywhere
called flubber yeah
yeah you got to just trust the idea yeah
yeah
i don't know you just got to throw it
out there
um you just try to keep it consistent
you know
um staying strong you know the team just
everyone just staying focused and
um just trying to create to the max so i
want to do is create to the max
good